bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors dénoncé un
confinement des droits de la défense
de quoi s'agit-il exactement
effectivement nous avons alerté le garde
des sceaux sur les conséquences de cette
ordonnance qui étaient dopés le 23 mars
dernier dans le cadre exceptionnel que
nous connaissons comme le disait votre
sujet de reportage les avocats s'adapte
à la situation sanitaire et accepte pour
accompagner leurs clients les défendre
s'inscrire dans certains aménagements du
fonctionnement géo dictionnaire mais il
ya évidemment des limites à cela nous
devons vérifier que les droits de la
défense sont suffisamment respecté ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans certaines
situations notamment lors qu'on nous
demande de façon à mon avis plus à fait
inadaptée intervenir éventuellement pour
assister nos clients en garde à vue par
visioconférence ou par téléphone
là évidemment nous avons parlé d'un
confinement des droits de la défense
nous sommes proches du ridicule en ce
qui concerne cette demande d'assistance
par un moyen de communication
électronique ont fait que dans ce
contexte d'urgence sanitaire beaucoup de
pays
pensa à libérer ou le font déjà des
détenus en france la garde des sceaux
souhaite libérer 5000 à 6000 détenus
qu'en pensez vous je trouve que c'est
effectivement une solution qui doit être
envisagée contre la période
exceptionnelle que nous traversons il
est d'ailleurs paradoxal que
l'ordonnancé du 23 mars qui vient d'être
prise aboutisse à quelque chose de
contraire puisqu'on va prolonger les
durées de détention des personnes qui
sont en attente d'être jugé donc on va
encore une fois gonflé les effectifs des
prisons qui sont déjà dans une type dans
une situation sanitaire totalement
catastrophique
et de ce point de vue là on ne peut
approuver l'arbitrage qui était fake est
en faveur
effectivement de la répression de
l'incarcération et pas suffisamment en
faveur des droits de la défense et de
l'élargissement de ces personnes
et quels sont selon vous les mesures qui
doivent être mises en place dans des cas
sanitaire extrêmes comme aujourd'hui
alors déjà ce qui devrait être mise en
place et un équipement de sécurité
sanitaire suffisant pour lui tous les
intervenants membres de la justice qu'il
s'agisse des magistrats des personnels
de grève des avocats des personnels
pénitentiaires qui ne sont évidemment
pas correctement équipés les invocations
des auxiliaires de justice il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui on leur demande
d'intervenir en prison sans il ne
dispose d'aucun matériel ni masque ni
jeunes époux alcoolique
donc vous pensez bien que dans ces
conditions là n'est pas possible de
laisser les avocats intervenir le
bâtonnier ne peut que s'y opposer ne
peut que les encourager à ne pas
s'exposer à ne pas contaminer les autres
ce qui parallèlement or tune atteintes
considérables ou droit des personnes et
où à la défense donc nous sommes encore
victimes et bien d'autres de nos
concitoyens du nain prévisions et d'une
insuffisance de moyens pour que nous
puissions effectuer notre travail de
l'essence dans des conditions normales
que pouvez vous nous dire puisque vous
parliez de la situation dans les
établissements pénitenciers que pouvez
vous nous dire justement sur les
conditions actuelles dans lesquelles
sont détenus justement les personnes
les conditions sont très difficiles
elles le sont déjà de façon habituelle
quand une somme dans pas dans une
situation de crise sanitaire puisque il
y à un surpeuplement bien connu dans
notre pays qui est régulièrement montrée
du doigt par les institutions et les
juridictions européennes et donc on
imagine bien que dans la crise sanitaire
actuel avec les manques que je viens de
poids ni pointé du doigt en termes
d'équipements sanitaires
nous sommes dans une situation
totalement catastrophique et la santé
des nus et des personnels pénitentiaires
mais absolument assuré contrairement à
certains messages qui ont diffusé de
action bien trop optimiste par
l'administration pénitentiaire
merci beaucoup serge havet liasse je
rappelle que vous aurez bâtonnier du
barreau de lyon merci à vous merci